[Musica]
immaginiamo la nostra mente come un
contenitore da riempire di informazioni
cominciamo ancora prima di nascere ed
abbiamo una vita intera per raccoglierle
per lasciare che entrino dentro di noi
questo avviene attraverso vari strumenti
la vista il tatto i sapori gli odori e
tutte le combinazioni possibili di
questi canali
abbiamo bisogno di informazioni di dati
per costruire il nostro pensiero la
nostra coscienza
le nostre sensazioni
i nostri sentimenti
le nostre speranze
l'allegria
immagazziniamo informazioni nella nostra
memoria e la chiamiamo esperienza ne
acquistiamo continuamente di nuovo e da
lavorare e confrontare con ciò che
conosciamo attraverso questo processo
che dura tutta la vita una volta
generiamo pensieri originali
idee che sono tutte nozze
a volte se possono essere strampalate a
volte sono originali
geniali
le condividiamo con gli altri gli altri
le fanno proprie gli altri condividono
con noi le loro informazioni
la loro esperienza noi li acquistiamo e
le facciamo nostre
ed è in questo modo che l'umanità
progredisce questo il progresso e grazie
all'informazione alla sua elaborazione
della sua condivisione che non
ricominciamo da zero ogni volta che
nasce un nuovo essere umano che non
dobbiamo riscoprire da soli ogni cosa
per portare poi tutto con noi nell'oblio
una volta morti
parliamo di informazione e di dati un
tempo all'informazione veniva raccolta
esclusivamente attraverso i nostri sensi
era il risultato dell'interazione
diretta solamente con l'ambiente a noi
vicino con ciò che ci circondava
il processo cominciava appena nati anzi
comincia molto prima
nel grembo di nostra madre e funziona da
sempre così per ogni essere umano
ricordo le mie figlie nella nella loro
culla reagivano alla luce al buio alla
mia voce al mio d'ore al suono della
pioggia fuori dalla finestra reagivano
in maniera estrema con pianto e sorriso
al contempo
non controllavano ancora l'informazione
però cominciavano elaborarla
acquisivano informazioni e pian piano
formavano la loro esperienza
crescendo poi l'essere umano diventa
capace di interagire con gli altri siamo
animali sociali
e lo fa attraverso i propri sensi
scambia informazioni di ricevere quelle
acquisite dagli altri a loro volta
attraverso i loro sensi per millenni il
bagaglio un informazione disponibile per
ogni essere umano è stato formato
esclusivamente da questo ma poi con il
tempo
l'informazione raccolta da altre persone
attraverso i loro sensi ha travalicato
il nostro perimetro
grazie all'introduzione di strumenti di
supporti per l'informazione
pensiamo alla scrittura alla pittura
l'arte ha cominciato ad arrivare a noi
da altri luoghi financo d'altri tempi
non era più lasciata la nostra
esperienza e da quella dei nostri
interlocutori diretti la raccolta di
informazione che riempiva la nostra
mente per anni per secoli il progresso
del mondo si è basato solamente su
questo è solo in un passato
relativamente recente l'informazione
anche quella indiretta quella che
avveniva esattamente in questo momento
ha cominciato ad arrivarci anche da
molto lontano
grazie alla radio alla televisione e
solo veramente recentemente grazie ad
internet
ecco che poi sono arrivati i nuovi
strumenti
i sensori artificiali delle macchine
capaci di acquisire immagazzinare e
trasmettere dati
tanti dati e tantissimi dati
ed ecco che non erano più solamente i
nostri i sensi a percepire l'universo
il nostro pianeta si è riempito così di
sensori di occhi di orecchio artificiali
che osservano e l'ascolto nel fissare
frenetico del nostro quotidiano e
producono quantità immense di
informazioni attraverso i dati associati
alle loro funzioni
questi dati raggiungono noi ei nostri
simili in ogni modo e regolano le nostre
decisioni guidano il nostro pensiero
influenzano le nostre vite le nostre
scelte come mai abbiamo potuto fare
prima d ora
è nata così la civiltà digitale
ora immaginate cosa succede quando
queste macchine invece di essere vicino
a noi disseminato nel nostro mondo
sono invece al di fuori dal nostro mondo
chi come me lavora nel settore spaziale
conosce bene il valore aggiunto offerto
dai satelliti
dai dati satellitari dalle informazioni
raccolte distribuite dai satelliti
artificiali
a me piace pensare allo sguardo dei
satelliti come quello di un occhio
amorevole paziente ed accurato molto
accurato che sorveglia il nostro pianeta
e l'universo per averne cura ed aiutarci
a non distruggerlo
ma non si tratta solamente di un occhio
i satelliti hanno occhi speciali che
osservano il mondo come non è facile
immaginare
proviamo a vedere come i satelliti
osservano il mondo
immaginate di osservare una nave e
immaginate invece di osservarla dal
cielo dallo spazio in questa immagine
vedete il canale di suez
nel momento in cui la enorme nave porta
container lepre given ne ha bloccato il
passaggio sulla sinistra l'immagine
mosse del traffico marittimo marittimo
in condizioni di routine normali sulla
destra il momento del blocco guardate la
quantità di navi che non riusciva a
passare
queste sono immagini prese dal satellite
sentinella 1 di copernicus dell'agenzia
spaziale europea e della unione europea
immagini radar che riescono a osservare
la terra
24 ore su 24 in qualunque condizione
metereologica con le nubi senza mai
interruzione
ecco a roma
roma vista dei nostri occhi
questo è come viene vista a roma dallo
spazio
da satellite prisma dell'agenzia
spaziale italiana
la osserva come osservano osserverebbe
dei nostri occhi
però riesce a osservare anche qualcosa
di differente riesce a osservare la
composizione del terreno che sta
osservando
con lo scopo per esempio di guardare e
studiare il grado di inquinamento del
terreno
questa è un'immagine del mount etna
guardate che bella durante l'eruzione
è questa invece sono questo è un altro
immagine presa da satellite cosmo skymed
dell'agenzia spaziale italiana
che osserva
oltre a ciò che l'occhio vedrebbe
qualcosa di incredibile riesce a
osservare l'innalzamento l'abbassamento
del terreno
durante fenomeni sismici
quest altra immagine invece è sempre il
monte etna
osservato da prisma
riesce a vedere il calore della
superficie
che di nuovo a osservare il materiale la
composizione del materiale del terreno
per poter capire
l'estensione per esempio di una
dell'eruzione
con gli occhi osservavamo gli elementi
naturali l'acqua il fuoco
la terra l'aria
immaginiamo di osservare gli elementi
attraverso lo sguardo del satellite
il mare
quest altra immagine è quella
composta del pianeta dal satellite smos
questo satellite
riesce a
osservare la salinità superficiale delle
acque degli oceani questo è
importantissimo perché ci permette di
valutare e monitorare lo stato di salute
del mare degli oceani di tutto il
pianeta
ci permette di valutare l'immissione di
acqua dolce
valutando quindi osservando la quantità
di
acqua nei nei grandi fiumi
ci permette di tener conto dello
scioglimento dei ghiacci di monitorarlo
il fuoco gli incendi
questa immagine mostra l'immagine presa
dal satellite sentinella 3 copernicus
che fa una mappatura dell'intero pianeta
dal punto di vista degli incendi
presenti in un determinato periodo
immaginate che ogni anno vengono
disperse a causa di incendi 4 milioni di
chilometri quadrati di terra sul pianeta
e questi incendi sono responsabili della
missione di aerosol di gas che
contribuiscono ad aumentare l'effetto
serra quanto è importante monitorare
monitorarli dallo spazio
la terra
questa immagine
del sempre del satellite
sentinella 3
da una valutazione
del nostro della nostra nazione
dell'italia
ne valuta la cosiddetta biomassa
vegetale che una variabile ecologica
importantissima cruciale per comprendere
l'evoluzione e i potenziali cambiamenti
futuri del sistema climatico e riesce a
farlo su scala locale
globale
sulla sinistra un'immagine
normale visibile dell'italia sulla
destra la biomassa una mappatura della
biomassa italiana e infine l'area
immaginate che dallo spazio è possibile
ascoltare il vento sentire il vento
osservare il vento
la missione eulex è la prima missione
satellitare che utilizza tecniche laser
per fare un profilo dei venti i venti
della terra e lo fa direttamente dallo
spazio si è incredibile questo questi
dati vengono utilizzati per capire come
il vento la pressione e la temperatura
l'umidità ai parametri atmosferici sono
interconnessi e contribuiscono alla
ricerca sul clima
ma dai satelliti riusciamo a fare cose
ancora più complesse osservare cose che
non possiamo immaginare con l'occhio
umano
questa immagine prese da satellite goce
è una mappatura del campo gravitazionale
della terra
e della circolazione degli oceani
con il satellite swarm
siamo capaci di rilevare dallo spazio
dati magnetici e su poter svelare
attraverso questi dati magnetici i
misteri della geologia che alla base
delle calotte glaciali che sono spesso
km riusciamo a farlo guardando dal cielo
con occhi speciali
però mi devo fermare un attimo video
vi devo dire qualcosa riguardo questa
quantità di dati
questo è l'anno di dante prendiamo a
riferimento la divina commedia la divina
commedia è fatta da circa 650 mila
caratteri
se pensiamo che un carattere sia
all'incirca abbia contenuto di
informazione di all'incirca un bite sto
parlando di sé l'intera divina commedia
costituire un po poco più di metà
megabyte
pensiamo ai satelliti copernicus di cui
vi ho parlato prima
questi satelliti che sono solo una
piccola parte ai satelliti osservazione
la terra del mondo producono ogni giorno
12 terabyte
i dati
facendo due conti
il contenuto di informazione prodotto
ogni giorno da questi satelliti equivale
a 20 milioni di divine commedie la
facciamo un piccolo sforzo e pensiamo
che sapete la linea commedia costituite
da 100 canti
immaginiamo di assegnare un canto a
persona al giorno perché non bisogna
solo leggerlo bisogna comprenderlo
elaborarlo
ci vogliono due miliardi di persone al
giorno un quarto della popolazione
della terra per poter
ragionare elaborare i dati forniti ogni
giorno dai satelliti copernicus
non ce la facciamo più da sola
processare tutte queste informazioni
ed è per questo che di nuovo la
tecnologia è venuta in aiuto dell'essere
umano e sono nati i computer
l'intelligenza artificiale
l'informatica in generale
e adesso sono le macchine a processare
questa enorme quantità di nati per
aiutarci poi affanno e miglior uso
possibile
ma riprendiamo il nostro percorso nello
spazio non guardiamo solamente alla
terra il cosmo è molto grande
questa è un'immagine del pianeta marte
presa negli anni 60 dalla sonda marina
il 4 della nasa molto romantica guardate
quanto è sgranata quante
approssimativa quanto poco contenuto di
informazione c'era
questa altra invece un'immagine presa
dal satellite mars express una mappatura
precisa
molto dettagliata dell'intero pianeta
marte che ci ha permesso di poter fare
degli studi approfonditi e guidare
preparare le missioni poi di ammar
taggio come quella
di perseverance ed ecco l'immagine
diverso di ansia la superficie di marte
presa da questa sonda e dal rover
marziano
adesso i dati li raccogliamo
direttamente sulla superficie ii e
lavoriamo e li inviamo a terra
quest altra immagine è quella di
avvicinamento al pianeta giove della
sonda voyager negli anni 70
l'immagine di nuovo molto romantica
molto bella ma di nuovo con poco
contenuto l'informazione
ed ecco invece l'immagine di gioco e la
superficie di giove presa dalla sonda
juno
guardate il livello di dettaglio
come andando avanti nel tempo siamo
capaci di acquisire ancora più contenuto
informazione
e per finire vi voglio mostrare
un'immagine molto molto speciale
il centro della nostra galassia
il centro della via lattea ripresa da
dal satellite xmm newton dell'agenzia
spaziale europea
non è un'immagine normale un'immagine
presa nel attraverso
un occhio a raggi ics e ci permette di
studiare la formazione delle stelle e le
sorgenti di energia
che hanno dato origine alla galassia e
l'universo stesso
insomma grazie alla tecnologia stasera
siamo capaci di osservare lontano fino
alle più remote profondità del cosmo
ricordate il piccolo principe
anche lui osservava l'universo da altri
pianeti
la tecnologia moderna ci offre strumenti
straordinari per raccogliere
informazioni di ogni tipo provenienti da
ogni luogo per osservare con gli occhi e
ben oltre i nostri sensi
la ricordate questa frase si vede bene
sono con il cuore l'essenziale è
invisibile agli occhi
non è l'informazione che conta ma è
l'uso che ne facciamo che fa la
differenza
non salveremo i nostri mari non
spegneremo gli incendi non
la che remo il soffiare in impietoso del
vento è arrabbiato se non impareremo
sarà meglio tutta questa informazione
che ci in onda ogni giorno non
proteggeremo il nostro pianeta e tutti i
mondi che conquisteremo un giorno se non
impareremo a rispettarli grazie ai
messaggi di allarme che stiamo ricevendo
già oggi e piu in generale non faremo
nulla di buono della quantità di
informazione che ci inonda ogni istante
sia essa buona o cattiva se non la
valuteremo a fondo con la mente si ma
anche con il cuore
ancora un omaggio a dante dante diceva
state contente umane genti al qui a che
si è potuto aveste aver tutto mestiere
non era partorì maria
nonostante l'informazione spesso le
nostre domande non trovano risposta
siamo umani non scordiamolo mai
ed allora ci vuole un atto di fede per
accettare la realtà
siamo contenti allora qui a al perché ho
parlato di come acquisiamo le
informazioni degli strumenti con i quali
le condividiamo di quelli straordinari
con i quali possiamo acquisire la mole
immensa di dati che riceviamo ed
analizziamo ogni giorno
lo strumento più importante però senza
il quale saremo fermi al contenitore
vuoto dell'inizio dei tempi e della
nostra vita resta solamente uno
e ci rende unici la curiosità grazie